i swear to god this might be the noblest
of professions robin williams had a bar
that i loved he said comedy is the only
job you can have where you can use
everything you know
and that's true
you can use more than you know if you
use what you think
use it
don't be afraid
don't let these bitch-ass [ __ ] button
your lip
say it anyway
how arrogant are you to think that you
deserve to go through life with no one
ever saying anything that you don't
agree with or like you don't have you
don't have to pave the jungle yeah you
can just grow up here and have a laugh
about it i mean your offending idea
comes first and i understand well that's
the other thing yeah people try and give
ideas right yeah exactly so so you're
not allowed to offend their you know
they jump in the way of the bullet and
say why are you shooting at me yeah
right if someone just insults maths i
don't know
it's not much yeah
and so
if you're so fragile that you think that
a joke about someone can destroy it well
you you you need something else then
when you're comedian when the audience
doesn't laugh
that we get the message
right like we you don't really have to
cancel us because we get the message
right
they're not laughing
our feelings hurt
right when we do something that people
aren't laughing
we like we get it
i don't understand why people feel the
need to go beyond that you know what i
mean it's honestly to me it's it's a
disrespect it's people disrespecting the
audience right like oh you think you
know more than the audience
the audience knows more than everybody
okay
um you know but
hey some things don't need to be said
some people need to be looked out for i
definitely understand that but um
not letting comedians work is you know
what happens is everybody gets safe
right
and when everybody gets safe and nobody
tries anything things get boring
absolutely so i see a lot of unfunny
comedians i see unfunny tv shows i see
unfunny award shows i see unfunny movies
cause no one's everybody's scared to
like you know make a move
you know that's not a place to be you
know we should have the right to fail
right
because failure
failure is a part of art
you know i mean it's like it's the
ultimate cancel you know what i mean
but you know
but now you know you got a place where
people are scared to talk that's not you
know especially in america you're scared
to talk ah
but you know that's what people want you
know got to make adjustments right you
know it's a weird time jim how are you
handling this comedy climate are you
sick of that [ __ ] question yeah
literally talking about that with mark
before you came in marching marks having
it mark's having a tough time i'm
nervous
that don't be drive the bus right
through it that's the point it does
that's what i've been doing but it's you
know you never know
i don't know yeah when you take due
process and burden a proof and you throw
that out the [ __ ] window right you
give it to a bunch of [ __ ] lunatics
who think that they're so goddamn right
i mean they're insane they're [ __ ]
insane there's so many people on twitter
that i follow like ironically when
there's like a big story i just want to
hear what the [ __ ] they're saying yeah
how do you spin this what's my favorite
one on the kavanaugh one was somebody
tweeted i lost male friends this week
and and then people were like consoling
this person like something happened to
her it's just like this this isn't about
you exactly this isn't this this is this
this is this poor woman's story right
and you're hijacking it and people are
consoling you because you're watching
something you're at home you gave
yourself [ __ ] jury duty and you're
gonna sit here and watch this thing that
you don't have a [ __ ] vote on and get
yourself all worked up it's it's some of
the best entertainment they love it they
love getting angry and you know what i
never got is the uh the norm hate and
they go well he was never funny like
what are you kidding me i never liked
norm like what he's maybe one of the
best of all time yeah no i'm had to go
to an apology tour for having an opinion
yeah yeah he didn't he didn't even he
didn't do anything he just didn't have
the opinion that they wanted and he he
had to basically yeah yeah he has to
apologize to 15 of the [ __ ]
population and the tonight show canceled
them and they said and respect for our
viewers like what i know people were
crying
who was crying at the tonight show
yeah it makes no sense and it's all
because he did it in the first interview
obviously
stop pointing that's triggering me i'm
sorry okay i want an apology from you as
a comedian today what what do you find
funny because i think like comedy
changes a lot it does
and
now these days i think maybe we're not
allowed to be
joking about everything anymore yeah
it's uh i don't know the climate is is
uh
iffy if you will
but you know as far as
me personally
i think the sake of the joke was
everything to me
and now that
we kind of have this perspective of
people's feelings or
get hurt and i listen i will defend
humor
until the end because it's a very
important way to communicate
and just because someone's saying
something that's offensive
doesn't mean they're being effect
they're trying to communicate something
so i wish
i don't know we're in we're weird times
but i was saying the sake of the joke
was everything for me and i've
personally had to reevaluate that now
i don't know if the joke is as important
as
this thing we're all trying to figure
out which is
how can we have fun with each other
it's i don't know we're in a tough well
this is a tough spot i i obviously i
don't have any
i don't know what i'm saying it's a it's
a weird time
but i think if things are funny enough
it trumps pcness
it can
yeah it is difficult
it's a nonsense that to believe that
some people deserve
never to be offended their whole life
you know um it's great and even in
universities
there's people that
i mean where better to hear different
ideas and argue the great thing about
freedom of speech
if an [ __ ]
is being an [ __ ] you've got the right
to call him an [ __ ]
it it's great
it's and it goes on it's a good system
um
it really is a good system and i i think
that
you should you don't close down free
speech because it's offensive you argue
with it you have more free speech and
you expose the people and
and uh you know i think that's the only
way to do it you shouldn't
you you shouldn't pave the jungle you
should make people
um
bulletproof towards it and
give them
uh the
it's it's about it's about education and
confidence and
um
it's just crazy and there are there are
loads of caveats to free speech that we
all agree with well you know you
shouldn't incite violence though
there shouldn't be people shouldn't
liable you shouldn't slander you food
additives you know watershed these are
all good but what isn't good is
um you shouldn't say anything that
someone will be upset about that's too
vague it's too vague and then you get
tip for tat
you know people say well if i can't do
that then you can't do this
um and it it just it goes back and forth
and it's all about people wanting to be
heard these days with your comedy do you
feel like you're walking on eggshells at
all do you do you feel more like nervous
about stuff you tweet and stuff you save
just because of the climate we're in and
everything that's happened
uh yeah like we're gonna go do stand-up
right now it's mostly trying out new
stuff you don't have the freedom to
to just talk and free associate
and then you know carve it back from
there because usually the process would
be you go way over the line yeah and
then you bring it you know and then
people go we hate you
you take away all the parts where they
hate you and then you're left with the
stuff that's
that's not you know that's on the line
but not over it is your starting point a
little bit more sort of tamer these days
oh yeah yeah yeah it's very calculated
and thought out and did that hurt your
ass though oh yeah it's way less funny
is that right other than it being not as
funny it's wonderful
it doesn't hurt anyone's feelings
anymore
but virtually no one laughs so it's a
trader but so that's really hurt your
career in terms of the fact that you're
you're an eggshell comedian and i don't
think like is that a new term i just
made it up just now
shouldn't comedy be some sort of sacred
place where you're allowed to say
whatever's kind of on your mind and like
if it's funny then it's okay
it used to be you know like like jerry
seinfeld always says the audience will
let you know yeah you know
when it's gone too far
because they they're across
you know representation of the
population yeah but uh
but now uh
it's not enough to get
you know
99 you have to get 100
you know most the audience wants to be
funny doesn't care about anything but
that they just want to escape yeah but a
tiny uh a group of people
uh ruin it forever